i took oxycontin for a year when i had
my hip and ankle replaced and if i
hadn't taken oxycontin i don't think i
would have made it because there was no
cartilage between both joints and i
couldn't actually sleep oh yeah there's
pictures literally like i have an x-ray
and there's a little chunk out of one of
my bones in me i couldn't sleep and i
couldn't put my hip in a comfortable
position to allow me to sleep so if i
hadn't had strong enough painkillers i
don't think i would have made it that's
one side of things the problem was
getting off of those can be hard and and
doctors don't really from at least my
doctor didn't know how to do it so i
kind of just did it when i was 17. and i
wanted to get off by my birthday which
is a stupid stupid to set a date when
you're trying to get off of these things
what you should do is go down slowly
enough so that your body doesn't freak
out because it's not your mind it was
like physical withdrawal and some drugs
you can die if you come off exactly and
people are like well i don't want to be
on them i don't want to be addicted to
something and then they'll come off too
quick and they can die exactly so people
have to be careful about that